when I came out of the closet as gay
there was almost no backlash you know
some people were kind of surprised I got
probably what you got which is a lot of
people said well you don't seem gay
because they want you to you know have
taffeta and sparkles and something but I
didn't get like a lot of anger really
but coming out politically coming out
politically suddenly I had friends
turning on me I didn't have any friends
that turned on me about being gay
nothing if anything it strengthened my
friendships right because we were being
more honest with or at least I was being
more honest with them but when I came
out politically just saying I'm I'm
frustrated with the left it wasn't that
I had said I'm a conservative or
whatever you want to call it but
suddenly I was getting a ton of hate I
mean I'm talking about people that were
invited to my wedding people that I have
been lifelong friends with saying you
know all sorts of terrible things and
that is kind of weird I'm Mary and
welcome to the don't earn this book club
I am if they talking with Dave about
chapter one of don't burn this book
which is on coming out and I suppose
first of all Dave I should ask you well
first of all congratulations on the book
second there are two comings out you
mentioned in this chapter maybe we could
talk a little about the first because I
uh I was very struck by it every gay man
has a coming-out story I forget won't
have a coming-out story um but you know
it's it's a reminder of how tortuous
difficult and some cases delayed the
process of discovering who you are can
actually be it's interesting cuz you
know it's one of those things it's like
like you I talk for a living everyone
knows what I think about everything but
it is a part of my life that I don't
talk about that often and I liken being
closeted about my sexuality to what I
think many many people right now are
suffering from which is being closeted
about their political views and I don't
mean that in the context of some really
racist political view
or even fringe political view I mean
people that have used that 10 years ago
were very moderate and decent now are
just simply afraid to say what they
think so in terms of my sexuality and
coming out I mean it's it's a true story
that I mentioned in there that the first
person that I ever came out to was a
friend of mine who is a stand-up comic
who is a he was openly gay comic I hate
the phrase openly gay but he was openly
gay comic named Mike singer in New York
City and I was 25 years old so I mean
that that's late especially you know I
think for young people now when they
hear you oh you didn't come out till 25
that sounds crazy to them cuz they're
out at like 12 or at least talking about
it as if it's not a bad thing something
like that but the first person I came
out to was it was September 11th 2001 at
about 12:30 a.m. in the Times Square
subway station so almost everyone that's
watching this can probably picture that
it's the most famous subway station
probably in the world and we were right
at the the shuttle train that's all the
shuttle does is go from Times Square to
Grand Central back and forth so you're
in this odd sort of purgatory place and
I lured this thing out this what I
thought was this like horrific secret
that I couldn't hide anymore and then
literally about seven or eight hours
later America was under attack I mean I
woke up from a phone call from my dad
who could see the first tower had been
hit and he worked in New York City he
could see it from his office and I kid
you not I mean I genuinely thought it
had something to do with me releasing
this
evil secret into the world and the way I
liken that to the political part is that
you know it's really hard to live one
life just as a human being just just to
be who you are and and put your life out
there and find some purpose and all that
that's very difficult in and of itself
but if you're closeted about something
in this case your sexuality or your
political thoughts you will lie without
even realizing you're lying you will you
will live more than one life you will
have two sets of friends you will have
family members that don't know who you
are all of these things and I think
people really do understand this now
from the political side because I hear
this all the time someone will come up
to me
you know at a college gig or something
and say you know I'm a libertarian
something like that or even the scary
one oh mama I'm a secret conservative or
they'll say I'm a closeted conservative
and it's like you know usually a young
person at college and it's like if you
start that path now when you're young
not saying what you think it will break
you at some point down the road and yeah
I think I think a lot of gay people just
have a an extra understanding of that by
the way I mean it also that story tell
it's a horrifying story about connecting
these two events your personal life and
then this terrible catastrophe and
you're gonna it is also something
reminder to me at any rate of the way in
which you know when we store things up
like that you know we create these sort
of catastrophic ideas in our head of of
what admitting what we are whether it's
sex a lot of sexuality or your opinions
your political views what that can do I
mean it means you've run through all of
these catastrophes in your brain and
then one has actually happened in the
real world and so of course you've
connected the two is the heart mind of
what this is like you know it's
interesting because it sounds crazy
right to think that I woke up the next
morning that sounds legitimately crazy
but it but it also tells you a lot about
what the closet is like you know I would
say but in the closet there's only room
for one and and when you are solo
whatever it is that you're not telling
people that you think it doesn't mean
you're right about everything by the way
you may have all the wrong beliefs that
you're hiding whatever that is but when
you when you are not telling people who
you are not sharing what you are the
only way we can figure out what what's
real in life is if we can map that
against other people when you say
something to other people you express
yourself in some way and then they can
say something back right like I mean
look you Douglas as a writer you put
your thoughts out there and then you're
gonna get a certain amount of pushback
on some things and then you might go oh
well maybe I wasn't thinking about this
the right way and then you can actually
change the way you think you can you can
look at things in a new way and when
you're alone in solitary and doing that
it it affects every part of you which by
the way you know I don't go too far into
this this there's only one chapter
actually that we cut in the entire book
is when I went really personal on some
of that struggle stuff and I just felt
it we sort of felt it was just going
into another book altogether but it will
lead you down a really dark path that I
think most gay people know about like
once you if you're not yourself if you
were someone else whoever that other
person is you will do all sorts of
things that are not good for the for the
person that you truly are and then that
being just to be via the other coming
out in this this first chapter and and
the light that you're first coming out
had on the second one the second coming
out of course is your your coming out as
well what do you call it no longer off
the left something what do you call it
that's that's good at well at least at
that time that's what I thought it was
you know it's like you you were one of
the first guests on my show at that
point so this is now the fall of 2015
and I finally started saying what I
thought and I was doing it from a leftie
perspective I was saying hey guys it's
our side that's having the problem here
you know everyone could say the
Conservatives are nuts and they're
whatever you want to say about them but
I'm seeing a problem here we're the ones
silencing people we're the ones calling
everyone racist we're the ones not
tolerating dissent or open inquiry or
any of these things and then suddenly I
started by saying it so this this is the
sort of metaphor to it it's like I
started saying that and then suddenly I
had Sam Harris on the first show and
then from that I had Maajid Nawaz on who
was coming from a similar similar
perspective despite a very very
different history right that Majid had
then I talked to you I talked to ayaan
Hirsi Ali I talked to Christina of
summers and it goes back to what I said
about mirroring
my reality against somebody else here
were these people that were extremely
diverse and where they were from and
their skin color and sexuality and all
of that stuff but they were feeling the
same thing about roughly what our side
was and and I think from that it's you
start getting empowered because you go
whoa I'm not alone there's there's other
people who think like this so again that
does go very much to the when you come
out of the closet sexually and then you
meet another gay person and you go whoa
they're not evil they're not this broken
crush you know destroyed thing and then
and then it allows you not to think that
about yourself so I started coming out
politically in effect and what I didn't
realize was that there was gonna be a
whole hell of a lot of backlash to that
I thought I thought people were gonna be
like oh yeah let's do it and and by the
way a lot of people did I mean that's
where it all started bubbling up and and
it sort of got me to where I am now but
I didn't realize that you know it's like
when I came out of the closet as gay
there was almost no backlash you know
some people were kind of surprised I got
probably what you got which is a lot of
people said well you don't seem gay
because they want you to you know have
taffeta and sparkles and something but I
didn't get like a lot of anger really
but coming out politically coming out
politically suddenly I had friends
turning on me I didn't have any friends
that turned on me about being gay
nothing if anything it strengthened my
friendships right because we were being
more honest with or at least I was being
more honest with them but when I came
out politically just saying I'm I'm
frustrated with the left it wasn't that
I had said I'm a conservative or
whatever you want to call it but
suddenly I was getting a ton of hate I
mean I'm talking about people that were
invited to my wedding people that I have
been lifelong friends with saying you
know all sorts of terrible things and
that is kind of weird you know when when
you just start saying hey Here I am and
then people go well now you're evil well
it's kind of connected isn't it I mean
I'm not surprised that you said you know
when you came out as gay didn't have
much pushback and I mean of course there
are people who do growing up in other
areas of the country in other parts of
the world as we know but I'm so not
surprised that you didn't have much
pushback then but if you'd have gone
back a couple of decades earlier or
several decades earlier
ah you would have had a very similar
thing to what you're experiencing
politically and it seems to me that the
common factor is but in in in the not so
distant past one of the objections to
having gay people around was a sort of
idea that basically gay people made
other people gay into subway
particularly younger that you would
somehow you know the proximity to a gay
it was somehow catching in something and
if there was I would that it were but no
but but the the the the political fad
effect in this is the same thing it's
this fear piece these people who are
around to have these ideas that aren't
absolutely in lockstep with a particular
dogma of the day it's other people are
gonna catch it you know if we're not
careful our kids will grow up not far
left and then where will we be it is so
about the toxic idea yeah that's that's
really interesting and I probably and
maybe it'll be for for for a next book
or an essay that you'll write that
concept really should be extrapolated a
little bit more because I think you're
right it's like you come out of the
closet and it's like your friends don't
suddenly turn gay right thank everyone
if they're straight there straight and
that's it I never met a friend that I
came out to and suddenly they were like
well I'm gay too you know I although you
could I guess you could have a closeted
friend too or something like that but
you're not gonna you're not gonna
convert someone it's not a thing but you
are right that when you start coming out
politically and you start talking to
people that know more things about you
so I started talking to Thomas Sol about
economics I started talking to Larry
elder about racism all of these able
people is a diesel highly dangerous
people with deeply contagious ideas but
what happens is in that case yes and
that must be the real threat that it's
not just you that they're trying to take
out at that point it's not just you that
they want to silence it's that they
might go holy cow some of these ideas
aren't that bad but they have
unfortunately and this was my
frustration with the left from the
beginning they had become so rigid in
their thinking
and of course I went I always say this I
don't mean every single leftist but I
mean broadly lefties these days and it
goes in cycles right like you know 20
years ago it was John McCain and Joe
Lieberman who of Republicans that were
trying to get video game violence to be
you know they didn't want Mortal Kombat
in video game stores so these things are
cyclical for sure it may eventually turn
around again but I think you're right
the idea is you come out politically and
you start saying just some of the stuff
that I now say you know I talk about low
taxes I talk about states rights I talk
about individual rights well that stuff
does spread once people hear about it
because I think it's a much clearer path
to happiness in a functional society and
if you don't want that well what what do
you got to do to those people I guess
you got to treat them as apostates and
and in effect that's what's happened to
me
and a lot of other people as deviance
that's what that's that's people are
made political deviance political
deviance I know this is it's a very
interesting thing as it tells us a lot
about a society you know we know it's a
sort of common place to say it but you
know you learn a huge amount if not
everything about it's a society by
finding out you know what is effectively
taboo or what is sort of deemed to be
socially unacceptable and one of the one
of the oddities about this journey you
described of you know coming out is no
longer on the left on the oddities of it
of course is that loads of people are
not on the Left uh you know government's
keep on being elected by majorities by
populations who are not of the left so
one of the things that it always throws
up is how does a political side that in
many ways has kept on losing
still have this stranglehold that means
that people are as fearful as ever
perhaps more fearful of coming out is
not being of a particular part of the
leftist tribe yeah it's it's super
interesting I know you've talked about
this a bunch too and I think you know I
go into it further later in the book but
I think mostly what it is is that the
left really did the culture game better
than the right you know if you're on the
right
your basic idea is you you sort of want
individual rights and then you you don't
really want the government involved so
you don't feel this need to be part of
everything outside of your family or
your work or your community something
like that but on the left there it seems
to me that no longer on the left is
there a unifying principle like it's
very obvious that on the right it
doesn't mean they always hold that ideal
properly but the ideal is individual
rights if you're a member of a society
you should be treated equally it doesn't
mean we call the same starting point it
doesn't mean some of us don't work
harder or aren't lucky or a series of
other things but on the left it seems to
me that there isn't a unifying principle
that brings them together so that leads
to the hysteria it leads to a certain
religious nature of if you aren't
exactly what I am when I am like it's
also that you have to change the second
they change right so it's like if the
second there for gay marriage everyone
better be for it that day so you know
Barack Obama Barack Obama ran first time
around against gay marriage and the
progressives of 2040 will hate that man
they will say he was a bigot because he
didn't change you know and they'll also
do it retroactively Lee when they
weren't even alive and have any
understanding of what it was like to be
alive in 2012 but but I think that thing
leads to a constant oh I feel it's
something about something right this
moment and that's good enough for me to
put forth to the world so if you don't
agree with it at that moment you're
screwed or you're evil or the rest of it
so then that leaves an awful lot of good
people just going all right maybe the
right isn't that terrible and and
generally what you find I mean you know
this is that they're not that terrible
but one of the other interesting things
about that by the way is this thing of
excommunication it strikes me as being
very interesting that the that I mean
there have been as you know I read about
this in my latest book in the madness of
crowds but this this thing of trying to
excommunicate people from the church of
gay or from [ __ ] yeah you know from
being black if they've not got the right
views and and and so on there's madness
that has been going on in recent years
but but it's interesting with this
excommunication trend also it exists in
my experience pretty much solely on the
put in politics on the left in that
mm-hmm to be told as you were told by
people you know you're not any longer of
our tribe because you've you've
effectively a pasta science you've
broken the rules you're out now one of
the things that was really interesting
is it being interesting about this is I
mean it I may be wrong there may be
countries where this happens but I've
never seen this happen on the right
because it I mean I I don't about you
but if somebody said to me you know
Douglas I don't think you're a real
conservative I would be like yeah that's
fine you know what you're not really
gonna be on the right we are going to
excommunicate you from the the the
right-wing group I mean who are you on
what met what gave you these magical
wand waving powers but but the but it
does happen and it does work his
excommunication this these in a magic
spell words it works on the way I think
I can give you probably the most
simplest example of what you're talking
about I mean look I make the case later
in the book for several things that are
thought of as lefty so let's just throw
gay marriage aside I happen to be
married to a man that's thought of as a
liberal or lefty thing okay so that's
one but that's an easy one I make a
pro-choice argument in this book that is
gonna piss off a lot of conservatives
that is there for most conservatives
that is the rail you do not touch but I
do make that argument I am against the
death penalty most conservatives are for
the death penalty I'm for some level of
public education I went to the State
University of
York at Binghamton I believe the state
does have some role in education I'm for
dignity with death that you should have
the choice at the end of your life I
mean these are things that are thought
of as lefty and I have several others as
well but I get no love from anyone on
the left about that meanwhile I can sit
down with Ben Shapiro that scary guy or
Glenn Beck that scary guy or the
scariest of all Douglas Murray
and and we can sign and I'm not a few by
the way that you've just all right we'll
have to arm wrestle about those next
time but but that's the point that's the
point even if we had some truly
intractable political position that we
could not get over after 10 drinks and
you know eight hours of doing it I know
you wouldn't excommunicate me at the end
and you know I wouldn't do it to you we
would view if anything I know this
Douglas because we've done this we've
had great political debates put it you
know not publicly where we don't fully
get there equally and then and that's
the joy in it like that's the joy of
like whoa maybe you know I say this to
Shapiro all the time about gay marriage
where his position is a religious
position not a you know you know he's
not trying to stop my marriage anymore
it's not that he fought for gay marriage
I and I'm very open about that but it's
like I believe that if Ben and I keep
talking about gay marriage we're not
even talking about gay marriage if the
if the future if Ben and I can just
remain friendly and have conversations
about politics for the next 50 years I
suspect that when I'm 93 and Ben is 89
or whatever it is he might actually come
around and be like I guess Reuben was
kind of right on that but there's only
one way to find out and so when you talk
about how one side purges you it's like
I don't how much penance can I give
these people if I agree with you on this
I agree with you on this I agree with
you on this this this and then have them
just spit in my face while the other
side I take some of the issues that are
most most heartfelt to them I mean the
abortion one that is the one you know
that for people on the right that they
and yet
I take the counter position and I know I
mean at the end of the abortion part I
say now that you all hate me let's move
on but it's like I know I know that
while they will disagree with me they
they will not try to destroy me and that
is just a fundamental difference well
you know there are two things I just add
to that well the first is the importance
of humility in all arguments and
discussions of humility means that we
can keep our ears open and keep our
minds open and the second thing that
often follows on from that is that there
is very little in the world certainly
very little in the world of ideas that
is more stimulating than the moment when
you realize that you might be wrong and
keeping yourself open to that
possibility seems to me worth doing but
I'm conscious that our times probably
are but we could go on all day but this
has been a great terrific game disabled
by get software racing star thank you
thank you from you that is a true
compliment and I do have to tell you
something publicly that I've said to you
privately many times but as I was
writing the book you know I had just
read your last book and I've read pretty
much you know I read pretty much
anything you put out there and the
entire time as I was writing sentences I
always had this thing in the back of my
head with Douglas Murray right this
better with Douglas Murray right this
better and I think I think I did a
pretty decent job for for round one
but let's just let's just keep fighting
the fight man and I appreciate you doing
this so thanks a lot it's a great
pleasure see you Dave
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our politics playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics watch our full episode playlists
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell